[Music]
president-elect joe biden plans to ask
the nation to wear a mask for 100 days
after he is inaugurated eight news now
reporter kate houston went to the
southwest part of town to see how the
community
is reacting with safety in mind
president-elect joe biden is requesting
american citizens mask up for his first
100 days in office
he hopes the combination of masks and
vaccinations
will help bring down cases of covet 19.
in clark county where cases are surging
some southern nevadans are all for it
they need to protect yourself and
protect others
no problem at all joe bardo says it's
important to think of these safety
measures with a historical context
obviously this pandemic has killed a lot
of people so
i think people need to wake up look at
history and
see what pandemics have done in the past
president-elect biden says the request
will last 100 days
not forever for some though it's been
long enough
i really don't like it i don't if the
kids don't have to wear it
and then out the whole outside thing
being inside i understand like it's
precautionary measures but i do not like
it at all
jessica jarrod tells me it's frustrating
to see masks not disposed of properly
i find them all over the floor rather
than in the trash can i feel like it's
horrible for
the earth and everything like that too
while the request is not a mandate
some think the community will still step
up and mask up
i'm very proud of clark county because
for the most part i see a lot of people
respecting that rule
and even if someone isn't wearing the
mask properly if you just say hey
just pull it up a little bit i mean more
than likely they'll do it just be polite
and i think that's that's pretty
reassuring kate houston 8 news now
and we also asked on twitter how do you
feel about president-elect joe biden's
request to wear a mask for 100 days and
for those of you who weighed in it's a
tie 50
say they agree the other half does not